Guten Morgen Ninus.
Guten Morgen Ninos. Buenoff dias Tim.
Ah. Hast du das in Spanien gelernt?
Eguardorianisches Akzent hier alles drauf, ja. Das könnte.
Aha.
Ja. Themensendung heute.
Ja. Ich äh äh habe mir auch eine passende Tracht dazu angezogen. Das kann man jetzt leider im Podcast nicht äh äh sehen, ja und ähm,
Ja, weiß nicht, vielleicht hätten wir auch mit Pahnflöte einsteigen sollen oder so, das war Peru, ne? Die Beweis beweisen wir unsere Kultur äh.
Auch ein äh das äh Volk der Kichwar. Kiecher. Ja. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie die sich guten Morgen wünschen, deswegen musste ich mit der Behörden und Landessprache spanisch äh.
Spanisch, aber ich glaube, in in Latino, Amerikaner wird äh äh nicht so gelispelt, dass äh finden die ja eh bisschen krummes. Okay. Das machen nämlich nur die Spanier.
Bald alles auf Wiki Leaks erfahren, wie.
Ja
Ja, jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich schon alles verraten.
Na ja.
Seit dem neunzehnten Juni Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete, saß Julio aus Sanchez in der äh,
In der Equadorianischen Botschaft und harte Anerkennung als äh die Anerkennung seines Asyls.
Und äh der Ecuadorianer hatten ja dann auch schon gesagt, ja wir versauen hier keinem die Stimmung so lange noch. Olympische Spiele sind und kaum waren die olympischen Spiele vorbei, haben sie angekündigt, ja am.
Jetzt versauen wir euch die.
Jetzt pass auf. Die Stimmung.
Und zwar am Freitag, am Donnerstag, den sechzehnten August, versäumen wir euch die Stimmung und irgendwie ein oder zwei Tage vorher hatte dann schon eine.
Ein ein hochrangiger Mitarbeiter aus gut informierten Quellen gesagt, dass dieser,
Asylentscheid wohl,
positiv äh beschieden würde und ähm daraufhin gab es dann einen einen Brief, den,
die Briten an, die Equarianer geschrieben haben, in der sie mit ähm,
britischer Höflichkeit und äh ihre,
Besorgnis darüber Ausdruck verliehen haben, dass die offensichtlich den
Asyl gewähren möchten und haben gesagt, übrigens äh wir können ihm dann natürlich
Wir sind gebunden an diesen europäischen Haftbefehl, diesen Menschen hier äh nach Schweden zu äh äh zu liefern, der ist bei uns durch, hat sich bei uns durch alle äh Assorchen, durch alle Instanzen geklagt und ähm,
rechnet mal bitte nicht damit, dass ihr von uns freies Gelei,
ja? Die sitzen ja nach wie vor in dieser Botschaft und kommen da nicht raus. Und haben dann gesagt,
Ja und dann wollte man noch freundlich darauf hinweisen, dass es ja den,
gibt,
der es ihnen erlauben würde, ähm.
Den Assange da auch einfach rauszuholen mit ähm äh mit einer Woche vorheriger Ankündigung,
Und zwar äh dann so aus dieser, aus diesem Brief wurde dann die, ich denke, weltweit die Meldung auf ein allen äh auf allen Internetseiten und so. Die Briten wollen die Botschaft Equadors stürmen.
Naja.
Ja? Ähm jetzt muss man sich erstmal, warum haben die überhaupt diesen äh dieses Gesetz ähm,
Das geht zurück auf einen interessanten Vorfall im Jahr Reh,
Und zwar wurde da äh die,
Yvonne, eine britische Polizeibeamtin,
schossen bei einem äh Protest vor der libyschen Botschaft,
in London. Und ähm er stellte sich dann irgendwie rausen im Rahmen der Ermittlungen, dass sie eigentlich nur,
aus der libyschen Botschaft selbst erschossen worden sein konnte.
Und zwar mit einer automatischen äh mit einer automatischen Waffe und ähm daraufhin hat sich hat haben die Briten sich dann dieses Gesetz gegeben, dass sie sagen, okay, wenn also eine Botschaft,
dermaßen missbraucht wird, dann können wir irgendwie innerhalb von sieben Tagen da alle Privilegien aufheben und da reingehen. Und auf dieses Gesetz haben sie dann mal freundlich hingewiesen,
in diesem Brief an äh Ecuad.
So so nach dem Motto, wenn äh äh wenn Julio jetzt hier weiter äh weiter Leute auf der Straße erschießt, dann holen wir uns den.
Ja
Aha. Tja. Ob das was wird.
Na ja, sie haben da ja nun mal freundlich drauf hingewiesen. Man kann sich natürlich ungefähr vorstellen, welche,
Ländern hat, mit den äh Großbritannien diplomatische Beziehung unterhält,
sie irgendwie eine Botschaft stürmen, ja? Ähm ich habe keine Bilder gesehen, aber es gab, glaube ich, dann auch schon,
ohnehin nach dieser, nach diesem Brief, nach dieser Drohung dann den Mob, der Äquatorianer, die sich vor den britischen Botschaften äh überall versammelt haben, um zu sagen, so, hör mal,
um einfach mal zu zeigen, hör mal, wenn wir hier rein wollen, da brauchen wir noch nicht mal ein Gesetz für, aber ähm
Ich denke, dass das ein bisschen heißer gekocht wurde, als äh es später serviert wird. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, äh dass die Briten da.
Da rein marschieren.
Ja, andererseits kann man sich auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie da abziehen. Ähm und das haben sie ja auch irgendwie gesagt. Also nach dem Motto, äh ihr könnt da irgendwie so viel Asyl gewähren, wie ihr wollt. Äh.
Sie haben also,
zwar irgendwie drei B oder so was,
Das heißt, der äh Julio sitzt da jetzt in,
Apartment mitm Balkon und ähm,
Wie ein äh Kommentator bei der Tagesschau anmerkte. Ähm auch nicht zu unrecht. Hat er da.
Das ist nur eine Wohnung.
Das ist eine Wohnung da drin. Und in dem gleichen Gebäude befindet sich sogar noch eine Botschaft. Und zwar die von Kolumbien, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Ja gut, das äh.
Also das ist jetzt.
Das ist sozusagen so ein so ein Kombi-Häuschen, wo äh dann vielleicht so die ganze Region auch.
Sowie hier in Berlin, dass die skandinavischen äh.
Schau mal, schau mal, ob das, ob das auch tatsächlich da ist, ob in dem gleichen ähm.
Mal gerade live.
Liegen. Ja.
Live hin, also die MBC ist ah nee, das ist das Konsulat. Ich wollte nicht das Konsulat, ich wollte Ambassy oder ist das das Gleiche? Kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Welche Straße ist es denn da?
Hier.
Ja, das ist richtig. Da ist das.
Genau, da haben wir's, ja. Und jetzt wäre natürlich die Frage, was da nicht hörte, dass in ah.
Unweit des Hydeparks. Was wäre interessant?
Ich hörte das in dem gleichen Gebäude noch eine MBC ist, dann nehme ich die von Kolumbien. Können wir ja kurz gucken.
Ach so, ne, das äh.
Auf jeden Fall hat er äh äh da jetzt sozusagen,
du das jetzt schon erwähnt, dass er jetzt diesen diesen Asylstatus auch offiziell äh bekommen hat, ne, waren wir noch gar nicht.
Also die die Protest, die die Protestanten versammelten sich, äh die Demonstranten und ähm.
Ist dann.
Vor der Equadorianischen ähm Botschaft war dann äh spannend, konnte man so einen, so ein Typ, der da irgendwie mit seinem Handy rumfilmte, fünftausend schauten zu, wie er dann da immer die Straße auf und ab ging und auf der anderen Straßenseite
stand quasi die Weltpresse mit ihren ganzen Kameras und so und haben gedacht, dass da jetzt vielleicht irgendwas passieren könnte oder so, ne? Passiert natürlich überhaupt nichts, außer, dass dann halt irgendwie ein paar Typen dann irgendwie,
Wie das so ist, dann äh irgendwann von der Polizei dann irgendwie abgeführt werden und dann äh hat man seine Police Botality Fotos und so und äh was ich ganz nett fand, da wurden am laufenden paar Taxen hingestellt,
für den Assange mit Schild vorne drin, Julian Assange fuhr dann so ein Taxi vor die vor die equatorianische Botschaft. Das fand ich schon mal ganz lustig so.
Natürlich eine katastrophale Fehlereinschätzung der Situation, aber okay.
Wie heißt er? Ich hab den Namen hier stehen, Panjano oder so,
Pantinio ähm das ist der Außenminister, glaube ich.
Equador irgendwo vor die Presse und sagte.
Hat lange, lange erklärt, äh was der der Sinn des des der Idee des Asyls ist und was die Bedingungen sind und dass er den, dass er eben das für gegeben hält, dass die dass der äh Assange in in in,
in den USA politisch verfolgt ist. Und äh das ist irgendwie natürlich auch irgendwelche Kodi CSG
dass dass die das Asylfragen keine Provokation,
sondern, dass es eben internationales Recht ist und so weiter und so fort. Und hat dann gesagt, ja, also insofern,
hat er jetzt bei uns Asyl. Ähm,
Problem ist natürlich, der sitzt jetzt also in diesem ähm in diesem.
Apartment dar, das Apartment hat, das ist also so ein Altbau, Knights,
Eine Tiefgarage dadrunter,
Helikopter und so ist auch alles eher, das war auch eher mein Wunschdenken, das heißt wenn sie sich jetzt nicht auf 'ne wirklich spektakuläre Aktion einlassen, hat er wirklich Schwierigkeiten
aus der Bude da rauszukommen, zumal die natürlich die ganze Zeit umstellt, ist von der Polizei zwischenzeitlich war es dann heute auch mal mehr Polizei,
was sicherlich auch einfach daran gelegen haben kann, dass da mehr Menschen waren, aber äh das wurde natürlich dann auch,
gewertet als eben die die Androhung, also eine Drohgebärde der Briten,
vor der Equarianischen Botschaft, sich dort aufzustellen und nachdem sie darauf hingewiesen haben, dass sie da rein marschieren können,
irgendwie hielt sich so eine Stimmung, dass die meinten, die stürmen da jetzt rein. Meine ähm,
Persönliche Einschätzung ist das jetzt unter keinen Umständen machen werden. Ähm und zweitens, dass wenn sie es.
Weil es ist irgendwie nochmal eine Sache, irgendwie in eine Botschaft reinzugehen und einen,
Typen, der aus seinem, aus seiner Haft,
oder aus seinem Hausarrest dorthin geflohen ist, daraus zu zuppeln. Ähm und es ist aber nochmal eine ganz andere, jemanden daraus zu zerren, der bereits,
über dessen Asylantrag bereits positiv entschieden wurde. Insofern glaube ich nicht, dass die Briten, egal was auch immer tun werden.
Es gibt hier Helikopterlandeplatz und zwar direkt auf dem Gebäude nebenan, das ist nämlich Harrots.
Ja, genau. Äh.
Ist eigentlich nur äh rüberschaffen. Er könnte aufs Dach klettern.
Tunnel, den er graben muss, ist nicht so lang. Das sind das kriegt man hin. Äh.
Das kriegt man hin. Naja, aber von unten ins Harrithm.
Laden leer gemacht also.
Nö, ich meine, das könnte man jetzt mal man hat ja eh so einen James Bond im. Da könnte ja dann einfach aufs Dach klettern, ja, zwei Agenten erschießen, die da oben rumlungern,
und dann äh mit so einem Batman-Seil sich auf die andere Seite rüberschwingen irgendwie.
Mit so einem Raketenrucksack.
Mit so einem Maß äh äh Lufthaken, der Lufthaken, den die da am Mars hatten, um den.
Raketenrucksack, die holen ihm einfach einen Raketenrucksack da rein, das können die ja irgendwie problemlos machen mit ihren äh äh Diplomaten teilen.
Vom Balkon dann.
Und dann äh muss das halt äh schaffen. Unbemerkt, was nicht ganz einfach sein dürfte. Äh wenn da jetzt so jemand mit Raketenrucksack sich da wohl bewegt. Also ich schätze mal, da ist schon was los dann.
Es ist auf jeden Fall aber das realistische, realistischste Szenario, was du jetzt da schilderst, wie der aus der Bude rauskommt.
Ja, weil eine andere Möglichkeit sehe ich da ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Wie waren die Reaktionen? Ähm äh Briten haben dann gesagt, ja wir sind äh sehr äh enttäuscht.
Und unter und nach unseren Gesetzgebungen hat Assange alles gemacht, was wir machen können und wir haben unsere äh unsere Verpflichtung gegenüber Schweden, das stimmt. Diesen,
Verpflichtungen werden wir nachkommen,
und daran ändert die Entscheidung der Equarianischen Regierung nichts.
Und sagen aber sie setzen weiter auf eine auf eine,
auf die Verhandlung und.
Die Equarianer aber haben gesagt, na ja, du, der äh Assange fährt morgen nach Stockholm, wenn ähm,
Schweden garantiert, dass sie ihn nicht an die USA ausliefern. Ja,
Und die Schweden haben gesagt, äh das äh das äh diese Zusicherung geben wir euch nicht.
Und Schweden hat dann, nachdem der, äh, nachdem die Entscheidung,
gefallen ist, wohl sich den equarianischen Botschafter her zitiert und ihm gesagt, dass diese Entscheidung inakzeptabel ist. Inakzeptabel heißt so in Diplomatensprache ähm irgendwie,
herrscht es harsche Kritik so. Was was ich jetzt was ich jetzt so.
Also ich meine, die USA haben irgendwie, die halten natürlich die Füße still
die haben einen, den sie da, der hat sich durch alle ihre Instanzen geklagt, den haben sie unter Hausarrest gesetzt, der ist den flüchtig, rennt in diese Botschaft rein. Jetzt war ganz unabhängig davon, was wir jetzt die Hintergründe sind
So, jetzt denke ich, was sie, also Äquador, kann,
will sein Gesicht nicht verlieren. Großbritannien kann und will sein Gesicht in der Angelegenheit nicht verlieren. Und ich denke, der einzige, der,
Da jetzt noch etwas machen kann, ohne das Gesicht zu verlieren. Das ist Schweden.
Wenn Schweden sagt, okay, wir sehen, das wird hier zu einer,
Ähm diplomatischen Krise, dass ja erst der Auftakt einer diplomatischen Krise. Das ist ja nicht der Höhepunkt, sondern ist der Beginn. Ähm,
Wenn Schweden jetzt sagt, okay, pass mal auf und,
irgendwie wir ringen Ecuador noch irgendwie irgendein kleines Zugeständnis ab,
wir ähm geben die Zusicherung, dass wir ihnen nicht äh in ein anderes Land ausliefern.
Denke ich, dass es auf jeden Fall das kleinste Zugeständnis, was eines der drei,
in Klammern vier dort verwickelten Länder machen kann und damit allen eigentlich äh ermöglicht, sein Gesicht zu wahren.
Hm
Im Netz wurden ja auch noch die Thesen durchgespielt, ob's denn äh Equador, äh ob Equador ihn nicht einfach zum Diplomaten äh nennen äh könnte. Schöner Gedanke, ne? Ihm sozusagen eine Immunität äh zu verleihen,
Problem ist, das geht nicht.
Genau und da gibt's nämlich noch eine sehr viel schönere Theorie und das ist,
und dann darf man ein ein und ihn irgendwie zu irgend so einer UN-Geschichte schicken,
die Leute darfst du nämlich auf den Weg dorthin und auf dem Weg zurück nicht äh ärgern. Und dann könnten die den quasi,
von der equarianischen Botschaft zur UN schicken,
Und auf dem Weg ist er quasi durch internationales Recht geschützt und den Rückweg könnte er dann nach Equador antreten und da ist er auch noch geschützt. Das wäre quasi so Ping-Pong,
UN könnte man den also äh nach Hause tunneln.
Aber braucht er dafür nicht Diplomatenstatus?
Den hätte er wahrscheinlich dann damit oder ich weiß nicht, ob man ob ein Sondergesandter, den ich ohnehin hat oder so, das Problem.
Weil ich also Diplomat kann er ja sozusagen dieses aber nicht ohne Weiteres werden, weil.
Wir müssen ja trotzdem mal die Kirche im Dorf lassen, da wird einer äh,
Auch wenn das jetzt irgendwie eine starke politische Komponente hat, aber der wird wegen einem ernsthaften.
Wegen einer ernsthaften, kriminellen Angelegenheit da äh gesucht,
den irgendwie da aus dem Land zu holen,
Also ich meine, das wäre unerhört. Also sorry, das wäre zwar witzig, aber ähm da muss man auf keinerlei Verständnis hoffen von irgendjemandem. Das heißt, wenn wenn Ecuador da jetzt noch weiter seine
äh diplomatischen Privilegien in anderen Ländern oder in in der Weltengemeinschaft ähm.
Missbraucht und es ist halt ein Missbrauch, wenn du wenn du sowas machst, dann brauchen sie sich nicht zu wundern, wenn die wenn dann irgendwann die Briten sagen, okay, jetzt ist ihr egal. Also jetzt jetzt macht ihr hier
und wenn natürlich dann, wie gesagt, die anderen Länder, mit denen Equador äh diplomatischen Beziehungen unterhält, Sachen, sagen pass mal auf Jungs, von euch,
Ihr bringt uns so gut wie nix und wenn wir Pech haben, macht ihr hier irgendwie
Tunnel auf, um um uns die die,
äh die einer Straftat verdächtigten Leute aus dem Land zu schmuggeln, äh da möchten wir mit euch lieber keine diplomatischen Beziehungen mehr haben.
Wenn Britannien da schon immer so konsequent gewesen wäre, dann wär's ja schön. Ich meine, man äh sollte mal so zurückdenken, dass unter anderem ja auch mal Herr äh,
äh London einen Zwischenhalt äh gemacht hat und von Spanien ein Auslieferungsbegehren war wegen ja,
große,
Verbrechen oder beziehungsweise Staatsverbrechen in großem Ausmaße und die Briten, die nicht ausgeliefert haben.
Dass die äh dass die sich da ähm immer richtig verhalten haben.
Na ja, das ist halt am Ende eben alles politisch so, ne? Rechts und UN und Diplomatenstatus und hin und her äh am Ende ja, aber es ist
Also die schon lange sich abzeichnende Situation, die äh sagt, hier ist alles äh vollkommen verfahrend, ist halt noch verfahrener geworden,
diesen Vorstoß und bin gespannt, wie lange dieses da noch in ihrer WG aushalten.
Ja, also es ich will ja gar nicht, ich will ja gar nicht sagen, dass das das ähm,
in Ordnung ist, was was da alles irgendwie läuft, ne? Aber was was du was sich, was man auch heute gestern und heute noch auf auf Twitter natürlich sehr schön beobachten konnte, waren dann,
die Streitereien immer noch, die du da hast zwischen den,
denjenigen, die sagen, das ist ja also alles eine skandalöse Verschwörungstheorie und äh äh oder eine eine skandalöse Verschwörung und die Briten
drohen jetzt sogar an, eine Botschaft zu stürmen äh wegen diesem Assange, dass wir ähm ist äh,
eigentlich natürlich undenkbar, wenn man sich, wenn man, also es steht in keinem Verhältnis zu den Vorwürfen, die ihm da gemacht werden, ja, also äh
die allein das in Erwägung zu ziehen, würde natürlich keiner machen bei äh wenn's um wenn's um irgendjemand anderen ging, ne, oder um um jemand anderen, der diese, dem diese Vorwürfe gemacht werden,
ernsthaft gegen vorgegangen wird und dass man eben wieder ein ein Vergewaltiger schützt und so. Und irgendwie so eine normale äh Diskussion über den Sachverhalt ist eigentlich kaum noch möglich, ne. Und wenn du dann noch die, also ich meine.
Es hat halt echt kein Land in diesem diplomatischen Kram, da Bock seine ähm sein Gesicht zu verlieren, ne. Deswegen, wie gesagt, denke ich, die,
eigentlich liegt der Ball im im Feld von Schweden, weil die mit den geringsten Zugeständnissen,
kompletten Konflikt entschärfen können.
Und jetzt müsste man sich halt überlegen, wie handelt jetzt Schweden ähm wenn sie,
Also das wissen die auch. Wenn jetzt das Interesse haben, den Konflikt,
und oder zuspitzt ähm dann muss man irgendwann mal auch deren Motivation in Frage stellen.
Und äh natürlich auch die Überlegung, warum sie denn sagen, okay wir äh können nicht garantieren, dass wir nicht ausliefern.
Auslieferungsabkommen mit den USA so sind, dass sie eine solche Zusicherung nicht machen können, wird mich auch nicht wundern.
Meinst du, dass Schweden solche Auslieferungsabkommen hat.
Das weiß ich nicht. Also ich ich verstehe sonst nicht, wie ähm warum sie diese Zusicherung nicht machen, also oder auch diese.
Die wollen sich einfach erstmal nicht festlegen lassen, glaube ich, ne. Wir wollen sie erfahren,
wie das so ist.
Ja, aber sie schwächen dadurch natürlich ihre eigene Position und äh oder ihre eigene die Integrität, die man ihnen dann noch zutraut.
Tja, Julia, ob er jetzt auch Äquadorianer äh äh wird.
Keine Ahnung. Also es, ist, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie das.
Spanisch.
Weiß ich nicht.
Was ich ja, was ich ja besonders interessant finde, ist du hast ja vorhin gesagt, das ist eine eine Sache von vier Ländern. Genau genommen ist es eine Sache von fünf Ländern und von diesem fünften Land, hört man einfach mal nichts.
Auf Italien.
Das ist ein australischer Staatsbürger.
Und und und die ducken sich einfach seit,
uns doch egal. Also das finde ich auch irgendwie hardcore. Ich meine,
Zumindest würde man erwarten, dass sie sich da in irgendeiner Form.
Positionieren, einbringen, keine Ahnung, äh vielleicht auch einfach mal vermitteln, ja?
Aber äh es macht so den Eindruck, dass äh Australien da einfach so dermaßen unter der Knute der äh Amerikaner steht. Was heißt Knute, aber zumindest.
Sich nicht auch nur im Ansatz trauen da in irgendeiner Form die Stimme zu erheben und zu sagen so, och hier ist ja unser Staat,
vielleicht mal erstmal nicht so böse, sondern irgendwie gilt da,
das haut drauf, Prinzip, ne? Die schämen sich da äh irgendwie für ihn. Das finde ich auch irgendwie ein bisschen absurd.
Ist vor allem, also.
Ja, also man man müsste sich eigentlich schämen, also ich meine, gerade so westliche Länder müssten sich eigentlich schämen, wenn ihre Bürger irgendwo Asyl ähm.
Beantragen, ja? Also ich wenn Deutscher losmarschiert und auf einmal irgendwo Asyl beantrag.
Erwägt ja noch nicht mal nach Australien zu gehen. Ich meine, das wäre ja äh.
Ne, also da hat er ja auch echt relativ klar ähm durch die Blume zu verstehen bekommen, dass es da nicht äh.
Bleiben würde. Ja. Naja,
Das weiß er wohl auch.
Aber um nochmal einmal ganz kurz auf auf ähm Julian zurückzukommen. Es bleibt nach wie vor unklar,
was der sich mit, also es war doch absolut vor, also,
Bis jetzt der Verlauf dieser Angelegenheit war relativ vorhersehbar. Dadurch, dass er überhaupt sich auf den Weg gemacht hat, in die equatorianische Botschaft war eigentlich klar, dass er,
Ich meine es äh der hat nach dieser nach dieser Sendung, die er der mit dem Korea da hatte,
das ist ja genauso gelaufen, dass der gesagt hat, ey,
Beantrage doch alles über den Equador, zack Bormona hat das irgendwann gemacht. So, das heißt
Bis hierhin war alles völlig klar, wie's laufen würde. Er kriegt dieses Asyl, es war aber auch völlig klar, dass die Briten das nicht anerkennen, dass er kein freies Geleit bekommt,
das einzige was jetzt noch überraschend war, dass die Briten einfach mal freundlich darauf hingewiesen haben, dass sie sich den da auch rausholen können, wobei ich das eben nicht so lese, als würden sie das ernsthaft androhen, dass sie es machen,
sondern einfach nur mal gesagt so, ey, so, jetzt komm, ne? Die Briten sagen eigentlich immer nur so,
Ähm so das war alles vorhersehbar. Und das ist keine Überraschung. So und der Coup bleibt aus, im Prinzip so, was hat der sich dabei gedacht?
Also was ist sein Plan da?
Ich denke, sein,
ist einfach jeden Strohhalm zu ergreifen, der sich ihm bietet
jede Möglichkeit, Druck und Konfusion und und und Verwirrung da zu,
einfach zu nutzen. Ich meine, sonst wäre er jetzt schon unterwegs,
er will das halt auf jeden Fall verhindern und ich frage mich auch, ob er vielleicht,
Meerweiß, ja, also ich meine, wir können jetzt sagen so, du brauchst ja keine Angst vor haben und so weiter, ist ja nur Schweden so. Haben wir ja gerade gesehen hier. Et cetera, also so,
ein paar Leute, die meinen, so es gar nicht verstehen, weil wenn man sich irgendwo äh äh nicht,
schlecht behandelt fühlen müssen, dann wäre das ja so Schweden so, da braucht man sich nur den anzuschauen, da weiß man, dass das da eben auch so,
nicht ist, ne,
Also wenn die da politisch was wollen, dann äh wird da die Justiz genauso gebogen und beeinflusst,
ähm wir an anderen Orten auch und von daher ist er sich äh unsicher und,
haben. Und die Schweden an meiner Tasche.
Na ja. Also mag's sein. Ähm da kann man kann man ja sogar.
Immerhin, immerhin tut sich jetzt mal was hier in der Geschichte,
dass wir hier unseren Dauerbrenner auch mal wieder ins Programm haben heben können. Ist doch auch mal was, oder? Ja. Ja. Wollen wir weitermachen?
Ja, muss jetzt mal langsam weiter, weil ich über dich gerade äh habe ich irgendwas übersehen.
Nee. Aber ich, also äh muss man auf jeden Fall mal schauen. Also werden wir noch lange Zeit mit zu tun haben. Und wie gesagt, meine
ich mag my Words, ich sage, die Schweden müssen was machen,
in meinen Augen diese diplomatische Krise,
aufzulösen. Bin mal gespannt, ob sie's machen.
Und ich sage Raketenrucksack.
Ja, das sind da, wie gesagt, das sind die beiden wahrscheinlichen Optionen, die wir hier sehen. Raketenrucksack.
Die Schweden ähm reißen sich mal zu.
Da ist noch ganz dramatisch. Wird auf der Flucht erschossen oder irgendwie sowas.
Oh Mann, ey, dann haben wir hundert Jahre Verschwörungstheorie, ähm sicher.
Aber da herrscht ja eh kein.
Es ist kein Wange.
Nachschub, von daher ist es auch egal.
Ja
Da gibt's auch Spaß äh am Gericht.
Ja und zwar gibt es den Paragraph,
hunderteins des Urheberrechts Gesetzes.
Ähm zum Ausspruch auf Auskunft. Und ähm jetzt muss man, also aus Anspruch.
Anspruch auf Auskunft.
Anspruch auf Auskunft. Ähm.
Ausspruch von Ankunft.
Da geht's also darum, unter welchen Bedingungen.
IP-Adressen, Personen zuordnen. Und,
Das Problem ist natürlich, es gibt den Artikel oder das Problem, ich meine, es gibt eigentlich kein Problem, Artikel zehn des Grundgesetzes,
Briefgeheimnis, Post- und Fernmeldegeheimnis sind unverletzlich
Beschränkungen dürfen nur auf Grund eines Gesetzes angeordnet werden, dient die Beschränkung, dem Schutze der freiheitlichen demokratischen Grundordnung oder des Bestandes, der Sicherung des Bundes und eines oder eines Landes,
So kann das Gesetz bestimmen, dass sie den Betroffenen nicht mitgeteilt wird,
und das an die Stelle des Rechtsweges die Nachprüfung durch also unter diesen Bedingungen darf man das einschränken.
Dass äh das Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnis. Und das ist bei diesem Paragraph hunderteins der Fall. Da wird das Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnis,
eingeschränkt, weil es gibt einen Auskunftsanspruch an denjenigen,
Rechte verletzt wurden, nämlich zum Beispiel
und so weiter. Also es geht darum, unter welchen Bedingungen darf ich,
von dem Internetprovider eine Auskunft verlangen, ähm wer, wann welche IP hatte, um ihn dann abzumahnen, ja, es hält eigentlich der einzige Anwendung,
Fall, den es da gibt. Abgesehen von ähm Cybermobbing oder irgendwelchen äh anderen Dingen,
sind aber dann nicht durchs Urheberrechtsgesetz äh gedeckelt.
Abgedeckt. So und jetzt gab es also ein,
inwiefern ist dieses Gesetz eingeschränkt? Und da sagt der Gesetzgeber, als er dieses Gesetz formulierte, wer in gewerblichem Ausmaß das Urheberrecht,
oder ein Anlass nach diesem Gesetz geschütztes Recht, widerrechtlich verletzt, kann von dem Verletzen auf unverzügliche Auskunft und so weiter äh unter diesen Bedingungen kann also verlangt werden, dass man das raus gibt.
Und die Einstellung ist also hier gewerbliches Ausmaß, das gewerbliche Ausmaß soll natürlich dann so den kleinen Mann, den Bürger schützen,
ähm und jetzt gab's also.
So steht es im Paragraph hunderteins Urheberrechtsgesetz. So und jetzt,
gab es ein ähm Fall der Form,
ähm Bundesgerichtshof landete,
äh gestellt und sich auf dieses Gesetz berufen und gesagt, ähm,
Hier ist kein gewerbliches Ausmaß gegeben und deswegen,
müssen wir die Auskunft dir nicht erteilen. Ich hab den die,
Fall selber gar nicht so genau gelesen, nämlich eher gar nicht, aber ich vermute mal, wenn es sacht, es ist, wenn man sagt, es ist kein gewerbliches Ausmaß, dann geht's vermutlich um ähm.
Ähm das also,
Klassischer Fall, es gibt einen Torent, eine,
Firma schaltet sich mit in den Torent ein, sammelt die IP-Adressen der Beteiligten,
schickt allen Brief und verlangt,
zum Beispiel achthundert Euro wie ein Bekannten von mir gerade abverlangt werden für das,
Herunterladen des Filmes Iron Sky. Ähm gleichzeitig haben die aber ähm in diesem Gesetz des gewerbliche Ausmaß nicht so richtig definiert,
Und da gibt's dann in unterschiedlichen Ländern unterschiedliche
Definition, was, wann ist jetzt also gewerbliches Ausmaß erreicht, zum Beispiel irgendwie, wenn das Werk sechs Monate alt ist, wird in einigen Ländern gesagt, OK, dann ist kein gewerbliches Ausmaß mehr. Aber, der BGH sagt jetzt,
Naja, ähm gewerbliches Ausmaß ist eine zu große Einschränkung äh und dadurch.
Ähm der werden die,
und ähm deswegen sollte das unter Berücksichtigung des Grund,
Satzes der Verhältnismäßigkeit,
weil sie sagen dadurch, dass wir es auf Ge,
beschränken, sind die Rechte des,
ähm des rechte Inhabers, des Urheberrechtsinhabers zu stark beschnitten und deswegen ist das nicht okay,
mit anderen Worten Artikel zehn,
Grundgesetz,
ähm wird noch stärker eingeschränkt, um das die Rechte des Urhebers zu wahren. Das ist das, was sie sagen.
Das heißt auch im Prinzip, dass sie das das Gesetz für unzulässig halten. So eine Aussage kann uns BGH eigentlich gar nicht machen.
Immer die sagen, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass äh jemand hier vom Gesetz äh eingeschränkt wird, also dass der Urheber sozusagen oder derjenige, dem die Verwertungsrecht übertragen wurden, in dem Fall wahrscheinlich eher,
äh ja davon eingeschränkt werden darf, obwohl's im Gesetz steht, das verwirrt mich so ein bisschen.
Dazu ist das Gesetz doch da, dass diese Einschränkungen gemacht wird. Das muss das BGH doch akzeptieren. Das kann man nur das,
Verfassungsgericht kann auch letzten Endes sagen, dass dieses Gesetz so nicht sein darf.
Da wird's ja dann auch im Zweifelsfall landen,
letztendlich vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, aber BGH hat jetzt oder der Bundesgerichtshof hat jetzt einfach entschieden, ähm dass das Gesetz so erstmal nicht geht, weil es eben der Grundsatz der Verhältnismäßigkeit ähm.
Was mich auch noch verwirrt ist, es sind doch auch bisher schon viele Privatleute äh über diese Methode der des Ausgangsanspruches ermittelt worden, wenn's diese Einschränkungen mit gewerblich äh äh gegeben hat, dann kann die ja bisher noch nie gegriffen haben, ernsthaft.
Ja. Das ist eben über diese unterschiedlichen Definitionen von wann ist gewerblich?
Also wann ist gewerblich? Ähm kann man natürlich so interpretieren, dass man sagt, okay, gewerblich ist, wenn du äh was weiß ich, fünf Mark dafür verlangst, äh dass, dass jemand den Film runterläd,
haben aber gewerblich darüber oder man kann oder man kann gewerblich darüber definieren, was der Verlust des Rechteinhabers ist,
und dadurch haben sie es äh dann halt verteidigt.
Motto, da ich ja einen theoretischen Schaden erzeuge, wie.
Gewerbliches Ausmaß, ja.
Würde ja bedeuten, dass jeder Einbruch sozusagen auch eine gewerbliche Aktivität wäre.
Ausmaß.
Ist auch gewerbliches Ausmaß. Nee. In dem Moment, wo mir der Einbrecherschaden zufügt, äh der für mich sozusagen gewerblichen Ausmaßschaden ist. Panzerknacker AG sozusagen.
Ja, aber das wäre nicht äh es heißt nicht, dass er ein Gewerbe betreibt, sondern es heißt, dass dein Schaden gewerbliches Ausmaß hat.
Also,
und das holt einer raus, dann hat er mir einen Schaden in gewerblichem Ausmaß.
Gut, das heißt, sie gehen da davon aus, dass das Kopieren dieser Datei äh das freie, kostenlose Weiterreichen dieser Datei,
Schaden auch erzeugt, dass er die alte Debatte, ob das nun wirklich der Fall ist oder nicht.
So und jetzt sagen sie ähm,
Es gibt halt sogar eine Begründung des Gesetzgebers, also quasi es gibt dieses Gesetz, es gibt eine Begründung und da steht quasi genau drin, wir haben diese
Einschränkungen in diesem Gesetz drin, weil wir das äh Telekommunikationsgeheimnis haben und das ist ein Grundrecht und der BGH sagt, ja äh das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Und sagt umgekehrt, es war ja schon schlimm genug, dass hier überhaupt gegen wirtschaftliche Interessen abgewogen wurde und ähm.
Deswegen sagt, sagt der Bundesgerichtshof jetzt, wir wollen hier eine effektive Rechtsdurchsetzung und das geht nicht,
man da irgendwie noch äh Telekommunikationsgeheimnis im,
im Weg hat, ja? Hinzu kommt natürlich noch, dass irgendwie nur in,
aber da könnte man natürlich argumentieren, bei bei Feststellung von Haltern, bei bei Fahrzeug äh,
sage ich mal Verbrechen oder Ordnungswidrigkeiten, die mit einem Fahrzeug,
werden. Ähm.
Ist das ja auch nicht anders. Da gibt's halt einen jemanden, auf den ist das Fahrzeug zugelassen und wenn dann jemand anders gefahren ist, dann haut der Halter den in der Regel dann doch irgendwann in die Pfanne, wenn man laut genug äh droht oder so.
Ähm heißt also, zumindest nach diesem Urteil, dass eigentlich bei Kleinstvergehen ähm,
jetzt einen Auskunftsanspruch besteht
und das damit fallen dann eben auch zum Beispiel so Überlegungen weg für diese sechs Monatsregel. Was sicher eine ganz spannende Definition
gar keinen Fall mehr von einem gewerblichen Ausmaß,
hielt sich ja lange so diese Regel, lad keine,
neuen Sachen runter, ja? Also ich meine die Hauptabmahner waren ja dann auch immer diese
hat sich eben nicht so empfohlen, weil ganz klar war, dass die,
dass die Rechteinhaber
dann da noch äh diesen Zweitverwertungskanal der Abmahnungen auch für sich äh in Anspruch nehmen, ne. Wie gesagt, Bekannter von mir hat jetzt achthundert Euro Abmahnungen bekommen für das für das für einen des Films,
Hat den irgendwie so achthundert Euro Abmahnung. Finde ich äh spannend.
War sogar noch irgendwie Scheißqualität, ne. Aber es weiß ja auch immer erst nachher. Na ja,
Deswegen also wir haben hier ein ein Gesetz, von dem ausschließlich,
Eine, eine, eine Gerichtsentscheidung, von der ausschließlich Abmahnanwälte profitieren. Niemand sonst.
Oh je. Ui,
Oje. Na ja und äh ist denn jetzt klar, ob das dann auch äh schon zum Bundesverfassungsgericht,
weiter getragen werden soll, besteht da jetzt ohne weiteres auch die Möglichkeit von den klagenden Betroffenen, dass dann,
zu treiben.
Ich hoffe es, also ich bin ja immer mit so den richtigen Details dann doch nicht so firm. Ich habe ja damals nicht Jura studiert.
Ja, also man kann ja jetzt nicht irgendjemand dahin ziehen, sondern du musst ja, wenn du beim Bundesverfassungsgericht auftauchst, auch als unmittelbar betroffener,
das tun. Also in dem Fall ja. Müsste im Prinzip genau dieser Fall weiter getragen werden, sprich.
Oder gegen die geklagt wurde, das weiß ich sogar noch nicht mal genau.
Wie so die Telekom AG, hast du gegen die Telekom AG wurde geklagt, weil sie,
ausgegeben hat oder die Telekom AG hat geklagt, weil sie es nicht rausgeben wollte. Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, warte, der Udo Fett hat's glücklicherweise äh.
Udo Fedder ließ sich das glücklicherweise auch alles durch. Wir reden nur dadrüber.
Wir reden nur darüber, ja, aber der hat ja auch Jura studiert.
Ja genau, den ist er auch einfach.
Dem wird ja nicht schwindelig, wenn.
Mensch hier. Du hast es ja einfach.
Du hast ja hier, warum.
Antragstellerin. Ja, okay. Antragsstellerin ist ein Musikvertriebsunternehmen,
Naidoo Records GmbH. Äh hat ihr das ausschließliche Recht eingeräumt, die Tonaufnahmen des Musikalbums Xavier, Naidoo, alles kann besser werden,
Einschließlich und so weiter. Ähm.
Hat die Deutschland L Deutschland, das ist irgendwie gekürzt, äh das ist offensichtlich die Firma, die die Rechte da durchsetzen soll, also die Abmahn.
Also kurz gesagt, die haben gegen die Telekom geklagt, weil die Telekom's nicht rausgeben wollte. Ist das richtig?
Erwarten, dass die Telekom vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht zieht mit dieser Geschichte,
ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber äh.
Also auch mal nur so ein so ein Ding.
Ja meine Zweifel, ob das stattfinden wird.
Outfit, ja? In den selten Fällen, wo das passiert, ähm weil sie eine Abmahnung bekommen haben
Da gibt's eine erstaunliche Häufung an äh deutsche Telekom-Leuten,
Das kann daran liegen, dass es äh grundsätzlich mehr viele Leute gibt, die bei der Deutschen Telekom sind,
Das kann aber vielleicht auch an was anderem liegen, weiß ich nicht, will ich keine Gerüchte streiten, aber bis jetzt äh
ist es da, sind da Telekom Leute ähm massiv vertreten, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen kann, wie wie stark die vertreten sind in meinem Bekanntenkreis, wobei ich glaube, dass ich da eigentlich das Evangelium äh ganz gut weiterreiche in meinem Bekanntenkreis, dass man bei der Telekom dann nicht macht
aber ähm also Anschlüsse. Ähm keine Ahnung,
Aber ich sehe auch die Frage stellt sich tatsächlich ob jetzt also man sollte jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht darauf setzen, dass die Telekom sagt, sie zieht jetzt hier für das äh Fernmeldegeheimnis von äh,
GH entscheidest demnächst erwischt wird, der kann ja dann von Bundesverfassungsgericht gehen, wenn ich das jetzt.
Vorstellbar. Vorstellbar.
Spannende Sache, also wir sehen,
auf jeden Fall ein ein unliebsame Entscheidung die hier stattgefunden hat.
Google hat der Google hat ähm die höchste Strafe,
die je in einem Verfahren wegen Verstoßes gegen FCC Commissions äh Richtlinien äh,
verteilt wurde aufs Auge gedrückt bekommen und hat zweiundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen für die Einstellung eines Verfahrens wegen Datenschutzproblematiken,
zahlen müssen.
Nicht fortlaufend nummeriert, ungekennt ohne Kennzeichnung so.
Ja, mindestens.
Google hat ähm,
zwei Komma acht Milliarden Quartalsgewinn, in dem betreffenden Quartal und die zweiundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen verdienen die, glaube ich, so in einem Drittel eines Tages.
So lange brauchen die dafür.
Die brauchen relativ lange. Also es hat die hart getroffen, ja? Also die müssen echt ein.
Verdiente Apple pro Minute.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also auf jeden Fall zweiundzwanzigeinhalb Millionen für Google, da mussten sie echt erstmal wahrscheinlich gucken, ob sie ein Konto haben, wo man so wenig von abbuchen kann.
Brauchst du.
Aus. Na immerhin, also ich meine.
Weniger Nachtisch.
Der Imageschaden zählt wahrscheinlich größer, ja? Was hatten sie damals gemacht? Also sie haben quasi
Die Settings des Safari äh umgangen, die Settings, die beim Safari-mäßig so eingestellt sind, dass du Cookies nur akzeptierst
von der Webseite selbst, die du besuchst, so dass sie eben diese typische,
von äh Werbe äh Cookies eben erstmal so nicht hast und das haben sie dann eben,
unterwandert, indem sie da.
Also sie haben in den Google Plus Button, der ja eingebunden wird aus einer,
anderen Seite, nämlich von den Google Plus Servern. Der Google Plus Button ist ja wie so ein,
mit dem wollten sie dir natürlich gerne.
Cookie geben, damit sie dich ähm verfolgen können. Auch wenn du nicht eingeloggt bist,
oder oder eben wenn du noch kein Google Cookie hast. Also sie wollten dir gerne ein Cookie geben und ähm der der Standard Setting von Safari hat da hat diesen Cookie nicht äh äh angenommen,
und was sie gemacht haben ist, sie haben dann ihren Code erweitert, um ein kleines HTML Form, also ein ähm ein Absendeformular,
dadurch hat Safari den Cookie dann gefressen. Ähm mir ist nicht ganz klar, ob das ein
Bag war von Safari oder vielleicht doch ein Feature, weil du ja häufig bei,
Ähm die kannst du halt häufig nicht abschicken, weil wenn du keine Cookies annimmst
weil ähm wenn das Form vernünftig programmiert ist, dann macht's halt irgendwie so ein oder so und versucht dir irgendwie noch
eine ähm,
verlangsamt bist, wenn du da irgendwie das das vorm Blutforsten oder irgendwie ebusen möchtest, ja? Also ähm.
Sie wollen sich, man will bei Inform sicher gehen, dass der der die Daten, die dort hingeschickt werden, auch von jemandem kommen, der das Formen vorher tatsächlich gesehen hat. Und nicht automatisches äh Skript oder
eben ein Crossside-Request kommt von einer anderen Seite, die dann Daten dort hinwirft. Ähm deswegen glaube ich, dass,
Entweder war's ein Back oder sogar ein Feature, aber auf jeden Fall, wenn es ein Back war, dann kann ich mir ungefähr vorstellen, wie der zustande gekommen ist. Äh letztendlich äh war er nicht dokumentiert und auch nicht gewünschtes Verhalten,
und äh Google hat das ähm,
in dem Fall tatsächlich ausgenutzt. Also man könnte sagen, sie haben eine,
Sie haben den Safari gehackt.
Haben sie, kann man, glaube ich, ganz einfach so äh festhalten, äh aber das ist bestimmt nicht evil, weil Google macht ja nichts.
Nee, nee, das das war nicht übel.
Nee, nee. So.
Und man sieht, was also was was sich an warum ich den Fall dadrin habe, ist ähm sehr interessant. Das
quasi eine eine historische, eines eine Strafe von historischem Ausmaß, da nur,
Tropfen auf einen heißen Stein ist, bei dem bei dem Umsatz, den Google macht. Und das ist so ein bisschen, sage ich mal, symptomatisch für ähm,
Diese gesamte Datenschutz äh.
Ja, aber ich meine, also das kann man natürlich jetzt bewerten, wie man will, aber zweiundzwanzig Millionen sind zweiundzwanzig Millionen.
Davon kannst du ja auch eine Firma kaufen und äh viele andere Sachen machen. Das ist äh jetzt auch nicht nüscht.
So und weiß der Geier,
so wie äh so schlecht wie Google sein Geld gerade investiert äh könnten sie auch noch diese Kleinstbeträge demnächst gebrauchen.
Ich meine, zwölf Milliarden Dollar haben sie für Motorola bezahlt. Das würde,
Diskussionen. Sparen wir uns jetzt hier mal lieber oder? Haben wir's?
Wir haben's.
Ja, immerhin noch mal unter einer Stunde geblieben, ist ganz gut. Ja. Denn wir wollen's ja jetzt auch nicht ausufern lassen. Gucken wir mal, was mit so passiert.
Heu. Das wird Never Ending Story, Alter.
Genau, aber ist ja auch gut so, äh dass äh beschäftigt uns dann hier weiterhin in Lokbuch-Netzpolitik.
Ja, ja, ja, ich auch dich.
Mehr haben wir nicht zu sagen, also gab jetzt nicht so viel Lustiges zu lachen so und so und äh so ist es einfach.
Aus, mach weg hier! Tschüss! Tschüss! So.
Tschüss. Tschüss. Wir gehen jetzt ins Asyl.
Irgendwohin. Tschüss.